this report did not find any evidence of
political bias or improper
considerations actually impacting the
investigation under review the report
does identify errors of judgment
violations of or even disregard for
policy and decisions that at the very
least with the benefit of hindsight were
not the best choices we're going to
adhere to the appropriate disciplinary
process and once that process is
complete we won't hesitate to hold
people accountable for their actions the
FBI director Chris Rea are reacting to
the Inspector General's report from the
DOJ 568 pages and in it Jim Comey the
former FBI director really takes it on
the chin or are some other developments
in there as we talked about with
chairman Goodlatte and Gowdy let's bring
in our panel Charles hurt opinion editor
for The Washington Times Charles Lane an
opinion writer for The Washington Post
and it's not Charles but matthew cottan
adi editor-in-chief for the washington
free beacon okay Charlie what do you
take from this report reaction to it
where we're going well I think it you
know the the most interesting thing is
the top line where you have people
saying that there's no evidence of
political bias in in the whole process
which is it strains credulity to think
about that because okay maybe there's no
smoking gun where James Comey said
blatantly I want to rig this thing so
that Hillary Clinton wins and and Donald
Trump loses but all throughout the
entire the whole report also shows
rampant political bias all up and down
the system whether it's whether it's
Peter struck and and his star-crossed
lover or if it's Loretta Lynch and her
decision to punt on the entire thing
after meeting on the tarmac with Bill
Clinton and hand the whole thing to to
James Comey or the you know all the
other characters that that clearly had a
unmistakable bias here that
Minh when you stop and consider the
final decision that they made when Jim
James come he comes out and gives us
withering indictment of Hillary Clinton
over the email thing and then says but
we're not going to indict her
speaking of Loretta Lynch I talked to
her and asked her specifically about the
Clinton email case back in February 2016
who's the ultimate decider at the DOJ it
depends on how the matter comes together
you know essentially it's gonna be
reviewed by those career independent
agents and lawyers that I mentioned and
they'll make a recommendation as to what
they've just what they thought they've
discovered and what they recommend but
the up or down yes or no we're going
forward or not
is that you it just really is gonna
depend upon what they find it wasn't her
yeah I think she comes off not too hot
in this report because really her
inability to sort of resolve one way or
the other
am i either going to recuse because I
met with Bill Clinton on the tarmac or
am I going to stay in and take the heat
she never came to rest on that point
which created the opening for Jim Comey
to come along and do his thing which of
course this AG declares completely
improper and thing about that violation
of procedure and incidentally it's you
know my take on this report is that
shows there's a little bit in it for
everyone because a lot of Hillary's
people are looking at this I know a lot
of Trump people are looking at this as
indication a lot of Hillary people are
taking vindication from this claiming
that it shows clearly the Jim Comey
intervened in this thing improperly and
that hurt Hillary's chances for the
election again I think that it is just
standard operating procedure you don't
comment on an ongoing investigation if
you're the flatfoot doing the
investigation and Comey
thought it was his responsibility to
somehow usurp that and he that's by the
way not my word but this is word usurp
he did it without discussing it with his
superiors and so on
that's pretty it's pretty heavy stuff
Matthew the the revelation of this other
text between Lisa page and Peter struck
the second part of it that comes out
just just a couple of weeks ago
no no he won't referring to Trump about
being president will stop it struck
response to page that is done before the
decision to slow walk
the investigation into anthony Weiner's
the the emails on anthony Weiner's
computer and the IG says that is the
place where the political bias could
have infected this entire thing and also
done right around the time we know that
the other investigation crossfire
hurricane was being opened into the
Trump campaign so and struck was
involved in both of them at 568 pages
this is like the war and peace of
misjudgment everyone from Hillary
Clinton who started all of this by
having those emails onto classified
server to the investigators stock and
page including Loretta Lynch including
James Comey including Andrew McCabe
including what is it some half-dozen FBI
officials who have been reassigned or
retired since these scandal has
developed all exercised graveness
judgment and I think all of them put
their own self-interest or
self-conception their own sanctimony
ahead of what were normal procedures
that should have been followed
throughout